[Music]
like that
how we doing what's up baby there it is
listen Luda Luda baby
um it's great it's one of those songs
that we forgot how funny the video was
um he just his arms just keep getting
bigger as it uh as he as the video goes
on ludicrous Ludacris his name's Chris
Bridges if I remember correctly that
makes sense do you know do you are you
well versed on rappers real name some of
them and some of them like and how like
kind of like
opposite their names are no like who do
you know do you know um snoop's real
name
I believe I know it what is it I think
it's Calvin Brodus yeah
you know method mans no I'm pretty sure
Clyde Clifford Smith Clifford Smith I'm
pretty sure Sergio chicon is our guest
today
it's well you blew it
Sergio what we do I just felt the need
to speak up because I'm sitting on this
couch and I feel like I'm on heroin it's
way too comfortable Sergio here's the
thing is we we pride ourselves on this
podcast about being organic and kind of
just bringing the guests in organically
with just an organic conversation so I
heard you have I heard you like snakes
and today I have a a a nice collection
of illegal reptilians that I brought for
you guys Sergio chicon
flip it flip it clip it
[Laughter]
Sergio
just a plain Snakes on a Plane Snakes on
a Plane snakes just come out of a
private jet on the vineyard where he's
from from the GOP yeah
um Sergio took an Uber here Sergio
showed up to the hey babe Studios with a
cart full of snakes in a plastic bag in
garbage bags we have pictures and videos
of it we'll put on the we'll put on the
uh on the episode here
um but you took an Uber wait we have
pictures and video we videoed Sergio
walking in and took pictures up and
walking in with a crate full of snakes
oh amazing a wagon full snakes yeah
they're they're uh I provide Tupperware
for them and then I wrap them up in
garbage bags and then I bring the blue
wagon to the delivery you guys the goods
wow the craziest shits are quiet snakes
from strange people I've met on
Craigslist so this uh transportation is
nothing I can't wait to Uber or Uber
pool how'd you get here
he's trying to spit this [ __ ] with me
like
Tupperware is what he put him in
tupperware Tupperware yeah yeah
Tupperware we talk about a lot about
Tupperware because I said it wrong I
said Tupperware but you said it right
yeah and I remember that episode as Sal
was irate he was he was furious with you
wrong yeah just to know you know if you
were on the fence about heroin it feels
like a comfortable couch
his phone just went off one of the first
times in the hey babe Studio she didn't
put her phone on silence zooming in and
out of her face make her feel stupid uh
which by the way I'm uh
I'm a PR I'm a polite snake Handler and
I asked the room when I first arrived
hey is anyone you know uh fearful of
snakes and I said Venezia and she's like
I just had never had anyone you know you
know ask me such a question so I'm
indifferent really and I was like oh
you're terrified I guess I am I'm fine
well so I could tell I can you you feel
it but the energy in here it's palpable
tension in here because everybody knows
there's snakes and boxes and garbage
bags feet away from us
the man who's responsible for
handling this came dressed like a 12
year old
with with uptowns and a big hat half
that's too big for his head actually I
gotta shout those out right oh geez are
mids uh oh geez oh those are nice to
make fun of these sneakers yeah Sergio
made fun of these well who those below
it's a Tapper Tony what the [ __ ] these
are Upper West Side good sneakers said
when I walk in today vanity a quote said
I like your fit they they immediately
put me in a bad mood they altered my
mood well you know what it is now though
the kids now Tampa Tony style
now Tampa Tony is like now a streetwear
Legends I'm gonna hey guys come see me
on the road all tickets are available
right now at savocanocomary.com uh my
fall dates are up to the end of the year
I'm gonna be next week I'm gonna be in
uh Hamilton Ontario and Toronto Toronto
we've added a show that's October 14th
and 15th and the rest of October we're
doing the Richmond Virginia the
carpenter theater Hershey Pennsylvania
they added a second show there that's
selling fast
um
foreign
that is all for October November we're
in Knoxville Atlanta and Birmingham
we're also in Louisville and Evansville
and then it rounds out in December I'm
going to Florida to Orlando Jacksonville
and Tampa and Tampa we added a second
show and I end the year over in
California I'm doing Santa Rosa
California San Jose California and we
are doing Sacramento everything's on
sale right now merch is up I got solo
merch and all the podcast merch is up as
well at salvolcanocounty.com hope to see
you guys on the road hey hey of Chrissy
UK hashtag cuk hashtag Chrissy the [ __ ]
I'm in London on Thursday both shows
sold out then Monday October 10th at um
Liberty Hall Fiesta in Dublin first show
sold out second show has a couple of
tiki wikis left Tuesday October 11th
Belfast is sold out Wednesday October
12th Galway uh we added a show there's a
couple of tickets left so Wednesday
October 12th Galway then October 27th
Baltimore Maryland uh October 28th
Philadelphia both shows are sold out I
believe maybe a couple of tickets left
in the Late Show October 29th Montclair
New Jersey also sold out November 17th
and 18th listen to me Toronto Canada
Toronto November 17th and 18th come to
those shows they're almost gone I was
told to [ __ ] tell you if you don't
come to Toronto I'm never coming back to
Canada again November 19th Buffalo New
York also almost sold out on Buffalo
Bill
um and then we got the south in December
Charlotte Asheville and Charleston all
tickets on sale January New Orleans
Texas and New Year's Eve will be
happening in Long Island tickets are
going on sale very very soon
um chrisdcomedy.com for Tiki wikis let's
have some fun tell you I'm gonna here's
a streetwear legend I'm gonna tell you
the reason why I bought these sneakers
right here is I went to the Foot Locker
in the Staten Island Mall to buy uh my
daughter sneakers for for school and my
baby Violet who's going to start daycare
wanted to buy her a little book bag so
so I saw a line of Chinese kids waiting
for these sneakers and I bought them
yeah
it's not covered
you gotta let that out you're gonna give
yourself a hernia I can't ever I haven't
a sneeze has never come out of my nasal
cavity since I'm a kid I have a a
deviated septum and I can't get a full
sneeze out but you should still cover
for no reason at all you've never been
punched in your nose you never snorted
drugs the Rosa goes like this at least
you're not there the girls went
we went back to the tape he didn't try
it's very liberating to be able to
sneeze like that I know should you have
tissues at the ready though or when you
sneeze I know but maybe you could fold
it and put it in a square over here okay
here it is and you can get toilet paper
like the toilet says she's not gonna do
it for you this is what I have that's
the only thing we have merch you want
some merch yes can I blow my nose into
one of the snakes it's a titi's Jerry
umtree right here we want to just say
thank you to Mackenzie who drew these um
what's that I said it's great beautiful
it's unbelievable this is the scene of
uh
you know
Michelangelo yeah there he is the turtle
the Ninja Turtle
s you also got the cool rug yeah there's
no word in that picture and Sal's hair
looks glorious I'm why am I why the back
of my head though oh I love birth
control I love that this the artist
painted DeRosa mad DeRose is angry in
that pic TT looks like work [ __ ] I'm
I'm I'm looking to to touch Sal's finger
that's the face you make when you box
yeah just just wax tight bottom lip yeah
DeRosa and TT been in the same room ever
no no wait I thought this was a hey babe
no no carpet what is it that sounds sick
whoa what [ __ ] am I just like pulling
these apart at one point I'm like I
might just pulling the Run
oh God bless you [ __ ]
that's actually really cool it's very
plush are you gonna put that outside the
house inside the house I think I'll hang
it off the Windows like we did with the
flags after 9 11. 100 yeah that's it I
like that remember that everybody was
patriotic for like a month of a month
every people had Flags
pick that [ __ ] up we need a tragedy to
do that now if you need have an American
flag outside your house so you think
you're like a terrorist unbeatable it's
amazing it's amazing what your people
have done sir Joanna by your people I
mean the Democrats
the Democrats don't get it no sir I
really wanna I'm just kidding around I
really
[Laughter]
I said I need details on what led up to
this fight
[Laughter]
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] yeah oh [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] she's got one move but it's
effective tell them what's happening so
right now there's a little person
fighting a woman a a big woman they're
probably both on crack and the little
guy just got kneed in the face and
knocked unconscious barefoot in a
parking lot of a gas station in the
parking lot of a gas station and car
wash yeah well she he's just taking
she's got this move down like she's done
it before the Anita yeah
also it was three in a row and he didn't
any of them Sergio was also
Sergio what is he doing wrong
break this tape down break this tape
down first of a boxing point of view
well he's he's susceptible to the knee
it's almost like uh you know if there
were a regular-sized fight is he's
getting like uppercut it with a knee
right so he needs to have a more of a
crossbar defense and he walked right
into it you think he could have started
he should have tried to grab her ankles
and bite them
and now he runs right after me he knows
all she has is the knee
Jesus Christ you addicted to me he'd be
on high alert
you think there was drugs involved in
this absolutely
wait is that the same guy I hope oh my
God
oh my God
what did he think was gonna happen
oh my God he's mad that was like a that
wasn't even just a regular kick that was
like a Kill Bill like like that was that
was like he went flying across the room
oh you want some type of account where
small people get into fights sorry I
love these accounts is that what it is
no no it's everything it's everything I
mean it's I mean we belong if we say it
wasn't entertaining it's just the thing
is it's like yeah you just sometimes you
have to just it's it's just a funny
thing
um
damn
Jesus Christ that it's like a golf hole
in one that is insane there's a video of
a biker got hit by a car and then fell
into the sewage drain
so we were talking that's ridiculous I
mean what are the chances of that I've
never seen it happen before the most
concerning thing about that video is
that the the motorcyclist doesn't have
shoes on the whole time that's just the
most jobs they flew off I don't believe
it let's see I like how they didn't go
right in but they went in at a little
bit at a time
see it's like I mean I mean I mean I
mean okay I'm in now
uh what's worse than being hit by a car
but sitting in the sewer right you we're
only seeing her
person drop when they hit when they hit
the ground in there it's probably like
they also got covered in [ __ ] oh yeah
yeah that's why I don't um
drive my motorcycle well speaking of
that Sergio has a has a uh electric
scooter that he rides around with the
helmet with one of those like big
oversized baseball helmets do you ever
get worried about getting hit by a car
in that because I always think I swear
to God every time you hear because you
hear it almost every other day cyclist
or or electric or scooter hit by a car
I'm like I hope it wasn't Sergio because
I I got I got more boxing sessions to do
it's just they used to say that because
the last time you saw me on my scooter
you had left me and it's on video camera
thanks to video uh by uh pimp you got
footage of Chris saying look how whack
he looks he looks like an Uber driver
yeah like uber deliveries yeah I hope
you die and I zoomed away he's gonna
hope I died
yeah yeah it's like you ever you ever
like uh get cursed out by uh someone
driving yeah
[Music]
I go two blocks up my my scooter
collapsed
like I
said
chin and and and and and
hands straight all across 23rd Street
I hope you die yeah like what's your
hair moving like this moments later you
fell asleep how do you feel about that
honestly I feel better reconciled
yourself within honestly to me honestly
I I feel like it just confirms what I've
always believed that I'm connected to a
higher power and I and I can make things
happen with my mind let me ask you a
question let me let's play this scenario
out I put all the I give you I I this
all the best to you I don't even like
talking about like this but let's play
this scenario out you say to him I hope
you die
two blocks later he goes up continue
playing car he dies okay do you is
you're still is your still the main
thought that you're connected to a
higher power or how do you then how do
you go on like what do you feel truly
what do you you say I made a joke yeah
you you rationalize it I made a joke
everyone knows it's not my fault I feel
terrible but or can you not live any
longer after that he's dead he's your
good friend good my initial first
thought would be my first call would be
to pimp to say delete the footage
[Laughter]
it's like I cause it now you know now I
gotta take make sure his family's taken
care of I gotta take care of everything
so you don't even mean it's just a
funeral you mean you gotta take care of
it I feel as if now his wife and
daughter uh it's my responsibility
financially and I got to make sure they
have but how do you feel how do you feel
do you feel like you killed your friend
I would feel like oh can you make the
distinction that you didn't like
everybody come on give me a little
leeway here I didn't know he was gonna
die I think I would probably personally
be like I I would feel guilty yeah for
it you can't for a long time and I would
feel I think the overwhelming feeling be
like Sergio's gonna haunt me for this
like I'm gonna be walking like I'm Gonna
Be Alone in my house and out of nowhere
I'm just gonna get a liver shot it's
gonna be Sergio with just a nice five to
the liver I could just imagine you're
overcompensating to try to make my
family feel good like you know
delivering like a Puerto Rican flag to
the funeral putting it over the casket
yeah you know pinagua stand in the front
like trying to accommodate my friends
and family too much above and beyond
yeah yeah like like supporting you know
the thing is though I think too is I
would feel horrible for like a couple of
weeks but then I'd be like you know what
this is an opportunity Sergio will want
me to make money off this so let's write
material about it uh that's what Sergio
would want and then I'll donate all the
money from those jokes to you know some
you know Puerto Rican boxing thing
not his family but a Puerto Rican boxing
thing Puerto ricanboxing thing.com check
out the website
should you ever be in a position where
you're financing my funeral I want to be
cremated I I wanted my ashes to be
spread out on the terrain to a terrarium
number one large python really you
really really do yeah I don't want to be
I don't want to be uh embalmed and you
know but it's not what you want your
Ashes to go no no I just oh yeah no
because people have weird requests like
yeah now I want my to be in the East
River I have a close Affinity to the
East River yeah yeah that's where I grew
up no seriously what I would do for real
what I would do for you is if you died
unexpectedly I would take it apart even
if I had nothing to do with it I would
take it upon myself and be like let me
see what I could do all right cremate
you your wish I put some of it in the
terrarium and then I'd give the rest of
the ashes of course to your family and
then the other half I give the Ghost
Face Killer from the Wu-Tang because he
loves him I know you didn't know him but
he actually was a bit of a stalker and
yeah yeah he was at every single one of
your concerts bro
um ghost is the man ghost you love ghost
face um but the thing is about ashes
they're annoying have you ever had ashes
is like after a while like you got a
dust though Ghost Face real name Ghost
Face real name oh wait uh that is Kohl's
yes Dennis Coles yeah Coleman he's cold
then it's cold he doesn't look like a
dentist no my girl's father died you
know five years ago and they cremated
him of course and they had before they
had the urn they just gave Jasmine and
her siblings they had the ashes in a
Ziploc bag yeah and I was like she was
like that's my dad it's sacred I was
like you literally have it in one of the
kids snack bags like it's hilarious
yeah yeah but my father was delivered to
my apartment it came in at UPS UPS
delivered it and my mother was like oh
you have your husband in my hands I
think I was like he was in a similar
[ __ ] yeah the cat came over peed in it
Cosmo wow yeah we didn't know what to do
we didn't have money for us so we had
him in a simplest shoe box for like 10
years
uh Sergio's got the cutest cat of all
time I'm not a cat guy you know me I
hate cats but his cat Cosmo it's like
what kind of cat is that it's a Persian
a persian's got that like like car like
looks like Garfield it's got like that
cartoon face you know it's it's really
like the fancy piece yeah it's a fact
yes it has a very
smashed smug face he has the the the uh
the characteristics of a dog but you
know it's interesting how we want these
items because they look so damn cute but
it's not a healthy way to live it sounds
like he's on cocaine all the time he's
always like yeah because it's a very
risk operation to open up the canal how
does the cat interact with the snakes
he's fine he's in different really
you'll let the snakes let me let me
which by the way I have four of them so
I want to bring one out we're going to
bring them out let me put it let me tell
you what bring them out bring them out
it's hard to yell when the snake's in
your mouth
um so so that
Sergio let me put for let me Sergio's
life so he's got okay he's got you know
beautiful wife and daughter they live in
an apartment I know they got a house now
but they were for a while living in an
apartment you know modest nice one
bedroom apartment in New York City dirt
is a two bedroom converted to a
two-bedroom but not really shout out
two bedroom conversion
[Music]
the city was notified
um
so imagine he would go away with me he
would come away with me first of all so
his space you know his space all over
the living room are are snake cages
different types of snake then he had a
pit bull and a cat right his wife and
daughter have no interest that our cages
their enclosures enclosures his wife and
child have it his wife and child have
zero interest in these animals he would
go away with me sometimes for a week on
end and his wife and daughter would sit
in the corner because they were worried
one moment a snake got out and then when
his wife would go to cook dinner for the
family she would have to open up the
freezer and in one section was dead
Frozen rats for the snake and the other
section the food for her family and
while Sergio was just out hanging out
with me posting videos it's good to be
alive The Great Outdoors
prisoners in their own home because of
his obsession with reptiles yeah it
feels like a conflict of interest yeah
Frozen about buying popsicles so now
they move to a bigger house and I think
the biggest thing is he has a room now
for his snakes because his wife I'm
trying to make it very clear to you the
snakes are only in one part of the house
and the rats are only in the basement
sure sure you got a freezer in the
basement now I got supper freezer that's
the way you got it like an early morning
where your wife's trying to get your
daughter ready for school and
accidentally puts his Frozen rat in The
Lunchbox when she meant to put a
popsicle and then Charlie's like that's
someone that's some lunchtime trade
though yeah I would make the most if I
had a Frozen ride all of a sudden I'd be
getting all the Oreos yeah um your cat
must be fearing for its life daily with
a pit bull and like and dozens of snakes
no they oh you know they cohabitat with
one another that they actually do he is
the Puerto Rican Ace Ventura I've been
calling that for a long time because the
way when you walk into his house you
cannot imagine the amount of space
that's taken up by animals and how much
love there is and it is one of those
things where like I you know like a cat
lady when you're like like he's a snake
yeah man man what makes a cat Persian
I'm not sure this guy is not not even
from Persia that's what I'm saying like
on the Bronx
her name is money backs for you to end
the yahoo.com that was the breeder I
believe it I got four Persians left yeah
money bags for you to Envy yeah Envy the
letter n and the letter b
yahoo.com
she had a web a web uh website that was
written in crayon right and she but she
read beautiful animals I was I was like
babe that seems a little suspicious to
me I wouldn't buy a Persian cat from
this woman but he's a Persian cat's
lineage at least from Persia is that
what it is not sure because if if when
name and Persian cats Persian shouldn't
we be naming every other cat with the
linear like why do they get to be called
Persians yeah there's a portion cat we
got this is the Irish cat oh you do they
do do that no I'm just saying like it's
all right yeah yeah yeah yeah but a lot
of dogs they do that I'm not sure what
cats like you got the Irish
yeah Cleveland yeah yeah yeah dogs don't
have it we asked this question we posed
this before didn't we do do animals have
ethnicity yeah yeah you got the Irish
Setter the German shepherd German
Rottweiler oh yeah I guess you're right
yeah there's a few of them but but it is
it's really not German it's just that
well the other ones are more better
examples like it's just from it's just
it was it was it was produced there for
the first time I think yeah yeah it was
like born and raised yeah I think yeah
German Shepherd's probably the first
time it was breeded was in Germany okay
yeah so they do they do do that like
yeah yeah but it's not as calm like the
German Shepherd is known for being you
know but if you had your cat born in
Puerto Rico was that a Puerto Rican cat
Puerto Rican cats are dirt bags they
have no tails
they open the door and just make
themselves at home yeah a Puerto Rican
cat is called a bodega cat yeah right
that's right
is anytime we're on a plane if I look
over his shoulder he's scrolling on
Instagram he's always looking at
pictures of snakes he follows everything
I lose the Wi-Fi it's like a snake
eating a deer
hey you want to get breakfast like yeah
I'll be back in half an hour I'm like
where he'll find a snake store or a
snake a place to go look at snakes in
any city in the United States a general
pet store he'll go right yeah how many
videos get him a gift card to Petco
every year for his birthday nine years
that's all he wants how many videos of
snakes eating deer
can you watch before it's too much like
before you like I've seen this I've seen
it yeah I'm actually not into that too
much I I enjoy uh unboxing videos so you
see how kids like watching our Box video
a video again I like people unboxing
that snakes you know no [ __ ] yeah I
enjoy that that's fun yeah what what do
you think drives Your Love of snakes
just the same I mean is that a stupid
question yeah no it's not and I since I
was a child Jesus Christ he asked Colvin
this this snake hook was coming out my
pocket I was like oh I don't remember
bringing my knife
just came out of your pocket yeah
you had a snake hook and you popped I
thought that was my knife and I got
worried I was like why would I bring a
knife
what's that called telescopic is that
what it is it's almost like if I was
like hey let's do a sketch where we
think of the most typical thing a Puerto
Rican guy from New York can do and have
let's have him have a snake hook and a
and a card of snakes and come to Staten
Island this is what it is this I can't
watch this this is the African rock
python
oh my gosh I mean that
he says he opens her that snake is mouth
wider than TT Jerry
I don't think it's like it takes like an
hour like they they yeah that might have
been a snake juice
eating full deer in five seconds now
Sergio is in the wild is it typical that
a snake can eat something too big and
actually die yeah that's like a way it
can die right yeah how long do they live
snakes it depends collubrids which are
smaller ones which are mostly harmless
uh you know snakes that you'll find
within North America like 12 to 15 years
and then boys and python days are larger
constrictors which get like 20 to you
know get it anywhere for 15 to 20 feet
long thickest constrictors could live up
to 30 to 35 years
of snakes what's like the oldest snake
that ever lives man I'm not sure but the
longest one it was like 28 feet and it
was a reticulated python uh so they're
the longest anacondas mistakenly they
always think that's the long that's the
thickest one okay anacondas are like
water Bowlers that's why they find them
in the Amazon and stuff and those things
they're not interested in messing with
people but because of movies and
propaganda and everything else they
don't want none unless but those things
will eat crocodiles and alligators they
will do they do that religiously yeah
yeah they eat deer 62 years old ball
python is believed to be the oldest
living snake before Social Security
High time with you yeah oh that's fine
okay
um do you wait so let me ask you a
question before we get to the snakes do
you or you could just pull them out
whatever you want to do
um do you like like snakes why do you
think they get such a bad rap like like
why are they associated with evil and
negative well I believe is is tied in uh
Through the Bible so we got condition
after Generation generation where you
think about God was wrong I'm gonna say
I'm a big reader I'm a big I'm a big
believer Anton Levine Satanist worshiper
the reason why the the fact that I know
that name I'm sure is a little
concerning to you guys yes I knew it
because my religious my My Religion
teacher sorry he was the music teacher
who was very religious in high school he
he told us uh that he was like uh he's a
devil that the song Hotel California
when they play it backwards it sends uh
satanic messages to the Church of Anton
LaVey yeah he was uh something like that
yeah he was the uh he was a Satanist he
was a Satanist he loves snakes and he
had a quote that everything that
everything in life needs to be there's a
beast in every man that needs to be
exercised not exercised I like that
quote Oh wow probably get a tattoo of it
what what made you get a feather
tattooed on your forearm at the time I
was like oh poetry the the quill the pen
quill is that yeah of course how come
you don't have a snake tattooed on you
anywhere if you love it it's coming slow
down yeah
you should do a body of a snake in your
head at the top that should be your
merch just like Beetlejuice yeah
you know it's very rare I see a snake
tattoo that I like right I just think
the body what got you into like because
you've been obsessed with snakes you're
a little kid yeah I remember just going
to the library picking up a book uh on
snakes and I read that [ __ ]
front to back at least 100 times over
and had a paragraph like a description
of each snake And I memorized and I
loved it and when I got my first snake I
just really enjoy them I've got zero
fear on your first snake or you're like
all right I know I like them now let me
get over it yeah I was a little bit like
you know uh
oh yeah yeah not a lot but I've been bit
how many uh recently I got bit twice by
the same snake which she's here with us
today
with us today let's bring her out by the
way it's uh it's a a good first stick to
introduce you guys to because she's a
king snake a Mexican black king snake
not very popular with the ultra right
okay
[Laughter]
such as a Mexican black king they call
him cake snakes because they eat other
snakes no so if you have a scent of
another snake on you now
they'll have a fight to the death and if
the king wins then it's gonna eat the
other snake the other state probably
won't even bother they're immune to
Venom and not to be you know not to be
one of these guys but a lot of people is
that snake poisonous poisonous is when
you ingest it and it makes you ill Venom
is when they they could make you sick
but do any of these snakes could any of
these snakes bite us and make us sick
it depends if you have an allergic
reaction I'm not sure what you're just
you know genetically what you're saying
what you're saying you guys are white
guys genetics yes you got stung by a bee
you see because
you're saying Venom's not poison Venom's
not poison you call it Venom we make a
mistake in calling it I call it Tom
Hardy right so all right so so I asked
you if you got bit you said not a lot is
dying in the corner by the way right now
you literally died I asked if he got bit
he said not a lot recently twice from
this snake recently this is all viral so
how many total have you gotten bit if
recently is twice I've been bit four
times when was the last time you got bit
uh like six hours ago when I was putting
her in that's why I was listening to the
podcast because she was being very
naughty no did she really bite you six
hours when's honestly the last time you
got bit like two weeks ago I was she
always it was what the [ __ ] yeah what
are you doing I was so whack because I
was trying to do a video about life and
I would like find your passions in your
life because you know for me it's
animals and it was like oh
[ __ ] video
he's like I'll show you my passion
go you gotta post that wait wait does it
hurt
like does it hurt yarn because that's so
fast but it feels like little needle
Pricks but there are some but they go in
though yeah but the thing is so this is
a lot of times a snake will bite for two
reasons either their food motivated they
listen this snake is not very bright she
smelled she it was my fault you dumb
yeah you're gonna say it's not bright
right before you take it out
you know she does she's motivated by
food so I can't believe it's in a
tupperware like you could also put
spaghetti and meatballs in there oh and
I will tonight I'm
show this naked smell left over Bernie
do you like the the
[Laughter]
um
graceful way I punked your holes into
the Tupperware
oh my God I thought that was like a
snake so wait a second you're this is
not a thing made for snakes you took a
tupperware jabbed holes in it like this
is where you're gonna live and someone
had someone to return this Tupperware
like my sister was like hey make sure
you've been the Tupperware back and I
was like yeah right do you like this
[Laughter]
Thanksgiving 2018. that's nice that's
nice so this is all Vira she's a
Craiglist find right oh that's good
that's on the up and up yeah
oh my God it's literally terrifying yeah
it is terrifying bro look at it why
Chris is black no I didn't realize it
was going to be like my wife stick I'm
sure you guys
Puerto Rican half Cuban steaks that will
make sound feel better
it's so shiny
when a snake shed that's when they're
growing so this is shedding no no that's
the reason why she looks so beautiful
right now you're not concerned
whatsoever that her face is going down
by your crotch no she's a sweetheart
and if she bites it's because it's my
fault I didn't wash my arms and it smell
like snake so wait a second no it sounds
like you're in an abuse it sounds like
you're in an abusive relationship with
your snake if she bites me it's my fault
yeah yeah so this snake will eat other
snakes and they're immune to Venom so
what can you give this so what do you
feed this other snakes oh no so I um I
like to give her a nice enrich like
enrichment meaning I'll give her mice
I'll give her chicks I'll give her
medium rats I'll switch it up but to
make no mistake if I see a snake
slipping it's going in her mouth no way
someone one of us next act up so if you
see it if you let me ask you a question
where would you see a snake slipping
yes you know one of my sex is not
appreciative of what I do for them oh
you would kill one of your own snakes if
one of the snakes was dead in the cage
one day would you feed it to this side I
recently lost the um a snake recipes
rest in peace haggy I'm out here still
rapping for you
so I lost and I wasn't going to feed you
know this thing no that doesn't feel
right yeah I have to dispose it properly
in the toilet
um for real do you flush them down the
toilet and I buried her where in the
toilet
stop asking questions I'm making me feel
uncomfortable
stop crying
he was prying right yeah because I want
to see yeah so um she's very sweet
actually these are uh you know
snakes that you'll find in Mexico and
some parts of Arizona and they're dope
man look at the iridescence underneath
how old she's probably like six seven
years old so let me ask you a question
if it decided to act up and go crazy
right now could it wrap itself around
you and just like you wouldn't be able
to get it off she will constrict but um
she just overpowers her prey by you know
like you know by moderate constriction
but the only time she's gonna bite is
when she missed mistakes the Handler for
food so that means you didn't wash your
hands and you smell like other snake of
other snake or a road because I smell
like molten Brown hand soap right now
dude very nice coming to England UK
tickets everything's sold out so except
for the second show in Dublin
when you tell their tongue they're just
picking up particles that's how they
smell okay and you know a lot of this
misconception that snakes are deaf they
don't have ears but they're not deaf
they can hear I'm not sure they heard
what we're saying right now they can
hear with no ears yeah interesting but
they're you know obviously they smell
very well they hear what vibration or
they hear me saying these words yeah
recently they said they're actually here
we know that just get decided how do we
know that
yeah
you've been doing and he just showed me
thigh yeah
that's crazy
as defense mechanism was to reveal the
widest part of his leg
he's been called a snake so you got to
be careful because so no one's just hold
holding a virus I don't know if I could
do it man I'll verse that might be I I
may have to say twice she's fine okay
here we go here we go they have all the
parts of the inner ear that we do
they're stapes called a column
Ella Harris is slightly different from
ours in that it connects to the Jawbone
enabling them to sense vibrations
however they can only hear a portion of
the sounds we hear so you deaf
[ __ ] you can't hear [ __ ] can you
tell at a glance if that's a female how
do you end up knowing it's a female
versus male
it's like that thing you said we were
talking about the other day if we could
pull it up quick to win cardi B posted
what cardi B posted here all right guys
we want to talk to you about Babel
should we talk to you about a lot and we
love it here uh for me I regret two
things not playing an instrument and not
learning a second language uh I feel
like I should have learned I mean I know
Spanish a little bit but I feel like I
should learn French and I never did and
I just feel like it's very romantic and
you can pick up all sorts of guys and
gals if you know French if you like me
and it's a foreign language that you
regret a lot learning in school it's
never too late to start with Babel
Babel's a language learning app
addictively fun uh it sold more than 10
million subscriptions and it is easy
bite-sized language lessons you can
finally cross learning that lewd
language off your list
um they have about 14 languages last I
checked and even though I don't you know
pimpy even though I don't uh I'm not
fluent I still play like the little
games the bite size games are all the
different languages so I know a little
bit now of 14 languages
um with Babel you only need 10 minutes
to complete a lesson so you can start
having real live conversations in a new
language in as little as three weeks or
if you're if you're really really risky
start it in 10 minutes other language
learning apps use AI for the lesson plan
so Babel Has used over 150 language
experts uh and they're voiced by real
native speakers not computers uh it's
scientifically proven to be effective uh
there's so many ways to learn from Bible
Edition lessons you can also access
podcast games video stories and even
live classes plus it comes with a 20-day
money-back guarantee start your new
language learning Journey today with
Babel right now get up to 55 off your
subscription when you go to babel.com
hey babe that's babel.com hey babe for
up to 55 off of your subscription Babble
language for Life guys I love doordash I
am happy that they're a sponsor I use
them at least twice a week
and they have saved me with doordash you
could just order food from restaurant or
establishments that didn't formally
deliver on their own prior to that and
basically that opens up a whole ass can
of worms for food and it's not just
restaurants but you could also get
groceries that you need uh household
essentials and things like that uh you
got back-to-back meetings you got
errands to run choice to take care of
what is the secret to Crossing that all
of you let's save yourself time with
doordash you just go on the App a couple
of clicks and that food is at your door
uh along with restaurants you love you
can now get like I said groceries and
other essential items you get drink
snacks in under an hour every time you
place an order for pickup or delivery
you're setting off a chain reaction that
helps give back to the people who make
your neighborhood unique because they
also support small businesses they have
3 000 Partners so it's not just a
national change it's also your
neighborhood go-to's uh from the stores
and restaurants the Dashers driving
around each purchase provides a new
opportunity for everyone involved
because with doordash is a neighborhood
of good in every order for a limited
time our listeners and get 20 25 off and
zero delivery fees on their first order
of 15 or more when you download the
doordash app and enter the code hey babe
that's 25 off up to a ten dollar value
and zero delivery fees on your first
order when you download the doordash app
in the app store and enter the code hey
babe don't forget
that's code hey babe
25 off your first order with doordash
subject to change terms apply
revealing the gender uh of the snake
um it's not a snake dick is it there is
it's called a hemipeen
no what is a snake [ __ ] look it up look
it up heavy pain
is fun board it's like two like it's
like two dicks two dicks wow snake dicks
have two dicks snakes have two dicks in
the colder hemipeen one wonderful
that's well that is not wonderful I take
that back right away nice taste double
[ __ ] what is that it looks like
do we have a snake
visually you could tell sometimes from
the anal van to the end of the tail the
anal vent yes
no dude
[Laughter]
if snakes did not look disgusting enough
yes hey I didn't think good I they could
look more disgusting and now with the
Hemi pain fully engorged it looks
awesome the hemipeen only come out like
that like when it's about to have sex do
snakes have how do snakes the beans come
out at night
yeah it's a smile like this so have you
watched it have any of your snakes had
sex or do you keep it all is it all boys
or all girls my snakes ain't [ __ ]
we're religious family okay whoa now
this one's beautiful
no
[Laughter]
so this is a lucistic ball python I'm
going to be honest with you this one
looks to me 10 times scarier than the
other one I agree with this one's face I
agree dude it's like aceverter he's like
not the white bat yeah I I agree um if
you put them
them or oh well we already said he kills
she kills all the snakes but if you if
you put all your snakes out in the room
together does it stand to reason shit's
gonna go down I'll ignore each other I
have a feeling of viral being actually
so food motivated yeah and it's part of
their their makeup yeah that she would
kill Pluto she would kill it all in
front of us who don't have a chance no
the result just for the views and we'll
give you a portion could we have them
fight here okay we'll do foreign
[Music]
[Laughter]
wow no I'm kidding now so this one again
also eats primarily mice and yeah and
rats do you ever if you had a mice
problem in the house would you just put
a snake out for real no no he won't do
that uh you know the cats would deter
any mice or rodents from coming into the
house so just the presence of a feline
alone is enough to do the job you've
seen one of your snakes do where you
can't explain what they're up to
uh
I would say
um
you ever seen them like I had one do
like a little head Bob like this
right
my workout he was like good [ __ ] yeah
well done so this is a little sister
ball python not to be confused with an
albino uh binos have pink eyes and they
have no melanin or pigmentation they
have a slight they have slight remnants
of you know uh the way that is
I know it's literally it's chilling like
I'd rather I'd rather eat the Hopkins
the thing going I know it's terrifying
but this snake I oh my God super Dasa I
would love for you to try it
it's not gonna happen it's not gonna
happen here okay actually they send
spear right look look look look look
look
don't be a dick no but they did but they
they do sense here
they they do sense fear though they
don't that's a that's a misconception
you know have you ever held a snake I
have when I was little I used to get
garden snakes and stuff but I was a
different person then
let me ask you a question I think all
animals to answer your question yeah
absolutely they have that you know that
intuition whether or not they're gonna
hear man they're gonna smell my
pheromones in my heartbeat and they're
gonna bite me this snake wouldn't
respond with a bite because of that it
maybe just feel a little uneasy and move
away from you because your energy ain't
right are these snakes let me ask you a
question would this snake and I'm asking
this for a friend would this snake
potentially be allergic or get upset if
it was given to a person who had a fake
gold bracelet from Amazon on their wrist
for a friend I'm asking because I have a
friend who has a fake call bracelet that
he got on Amazon are you being serious
do you think that they potentially sense
fake jewelry
you know quite possibly I mean then I'm
just gonna have to pass for my fight
[Music]
no no you know if we do that snake hot
sauce that we ate the other day would
they feel hot sauce would that not sure
freak out I think I'll just ignore it it
might I think I had the same effects are
they cold blooded or hot blooded
cold-blooded
but just stand up and put it put it in
front of Sal's face like it's friend of
mine just quickly just stand up don't
give it to him but I just want you to
experience what I'm experiencing Sal how
[ __ ] terrifying it is the statue
it's looking still looking at me Sergio
it's not it's not gonna do anything
you're not gonna touch it
no what's happened is you're gonna touch
it and it's going to jolt at me and bite
my nose off
give it the back of your finger just go
along with the scales if it bites you
what happens nothing happens
no it's not venomous there you go it
feels nice right it feels because the
butt of a 12 year old
in the best possible make no mistakes my
shit's adult
[Laughter]
oh my God I thought it was gonna be I
thought you guys were gonna jump at the
opportunity I don't know like a smaller
one I don't they just get bigger and
bigger how old I want to impress you
guys Pluto
how old is infinity it's like size
doesn't matter it's all about
personality
noodles around six years old he's also
on Craigslist fine and the guy who sold
it to me maybe it makes me feel great
met me at Tompkins Square Park in the
same Tupperware this is where plural
came in and I waited like three hours I
also to be real with you guys I think my
love for animals but also acquiring them
kind of goes back to my addiction it's
almost like getting drugs and like
waiting for like the drug so when I get
them off of Craigslist it's always like
I was gonna say the entire process is
the drug process as well you're going on
to Craigslist and meeting the guy in
Thompson Square Park
rehab
a plastic bag and so I meet this girl
that I know from the gym sees me it's
like Sergio how are you I'm like I'm
doing well hi how are you I'm at the
entrance to Tompkins and she's like what
are you doing here I'm like I'm just
waiting for delivery she's like what
what yeah she's back Matt she's prying
like she's like I'm like I I got a snake
coming in she's like what and she's like
what do you do with them and I was like
oh here it is right now the guy comes
he's like yo my man serves like he knew
me for years she canceled her sessions
like dangling in the middle of July sun
and he goes you like that and I was like
yeah man I love it man and he's like
check it out it's clean it's clean and
I'm like yeah man you know you always
check the snakes for mites which I like
fleas to a dog oh and you would see the
might right on them right there so you
know check them make sure they're
healthy I explained to him I said listen
I see this thing it's sick I'm not
giving you that 250. right that's all
costs 250 yeah I gotta do I I I I got
him down I have a few questions one it's
very very very uncomfortable sitting
here
I know I if I was that close because you
don't just go like this I know I know
it's like the snake on the couch let him
explore yeah explore yeah
yo if you guys are not handling this one
Daddy's got bigger and bigger guys
yeah they call them ball pythons b-a-l-l
because that defense mechanism is to
roll up on the ball someone that's what
you did
your snakes like in your house before Oh
my God when we were on the road once it
happened six times within a pack and his
wife
in the [ __ ] bathroom for three days
I leave the door wide open why do you do
that
and oversight because my other
enclosures used to have like locks it's
like a sliding door so I'll change the
water and I'm like
[Applause]
hey man come back in the afternoon like
how you guys and then there's no snake
in there do you always find them in the
same hiding spot or you find a
difference there's always you know
snakes because they don't have arms or
legs they like to be Inc so when people
ask me oh my God how can you put it in
tupperware they actually feel very
secure in here anytime you see a snake
like hiding they're in a on the crevice
you know you know behind rocks they like
small type places it's where they feel
most comfortable if I was to put this
snake right in the middle of the floor
he would like like Square me away they
like to be against the wall right they
want to feel secure what is its face
looks like it's like stitched you see
like its face like the Joker it looks
like the Joker it's like the Joker above
uh the mouth of Pluto is heat pits and
that's how that's the difference between
a python and a bowl constrictor the
pythons they have heat pits he pits
meaning what do you mean that's
different than an event in the dreams
right all right so it's like if there's
a prey nearby they can't really see well
they can smell but they can also feel
the heat so a lot of times when I'm
feeding it frozen and if it can't take
it then it gets out the kitchen that's
correct now so they can't see well but
they feel heat do they know every time
they're gonna lunge for something that
they think is food for them they can't
see well they feel Heat
do they not know do they not know what
they're lunging for well I think it's a
combination of both the smell of a
rodent but like the heat of eroded so if
I feed it like a cold like a loading
heat though yeah that rodent is
different I do have a mouse live in my
apartment do you think I could smell
that on me no the neighbors are doing
construction it's not because we're
dirty
house yeah that's
the Exterminator came over I was like
you know we keep a very clean house not
because we're dirty the neighbors are
doing construction he goes every
neighbor's everybody's everybody tells
the Exterminator their neighbors are
doing construction
I think I know where the problems are
yeah do you do you buy the the when the
guy brought you the snake do you get
them as babies or you can take a snake
at years old yeah so Pluto was probably
like a year or two old is it this side
like are they born like no this thing is
probably born six eight inches and what
is it now he's probably like three and a
half feet oh so you ever had a baby
snake like a little like dude are they
Q2 like puppies would be cute I mean
they don't have the same sentimental
connection with them because
dogs in particular are more emotional
creatures and they greet you at the door
cat's a little more aloof you know yeah
but they can be but snakes are
indifferent they're cold blooded this
guy's gotta look at the snake he's got
on his neck but you get you you get love
from them I I got I wouldn't I I really
do love my animals right but if this
snake was to pass away tomorrow I
wouldn't feel the same despair I would
with a dog I understand you know I
understand but I will feel bad yeah I
remember when your dog unfortunately
passed away you canceled gigs last
minute
request from you Sergio
I bury my animals in my [ __ ] yard
so when the guy when the guy brings a
snake to you that's already years old
you'll immediately handle it doesn't
have to be a period of familiarity yeah
absolutely there was another snake I
acquired I didn't bring her because
she's really snooty her name is uh
Venom Venom's here
that's the name of the episode
she's not she's a she's a carpet python
from Australia black and yellow and her
owner uh yellow black and now the sister
acquired all these animals you know and
uh she was given up for adoption and
this snake was in bad shape dehydrated
had a mouth sore you know and uh yeah it
was like it was on the streets the
snake's like I'll suck your dick
snake's like y'all right now
[Laughter]
so yeah I went to the vet got some uh uh
you know some medicine yeah and me and
the family you know administer the shots
weekly you know and and hydrated you're
administering shots yeah dude he's like
literally
in between the scales
you're you're injecting the steak with a
needle yeah yeah that was a family
effect I held the head and my wife
administered a shot and my daughter
because I wanted her to participate I
don't want her to feel left out right I
said hold the anal vent okay
how many times a week do you think your
wife talks to like her friends or her
sisters and it's like you know marriage
is about compromise
I love Sergio but it's about compromise
I have to keep reminding myself that he
loves snakes and we have to love it too
and sometimes I have to inject them with
medicine in their anal vent and that's
okay
and Charlie's okay with it and we're
okay
let's talk about it
for our fans to get snakes off
Craigslist what do you look for
yeah what's a safe Craigslist snake
honestly man if you never bought a snake
before I wouldn't go on Craigslist
because it could be some shady dealings
there
[ __ ] you've seen okay I mean listen I've
seen uh
I seen a still picture of a snake for
sale on a newspaper the background of
the picture it was pouring on on like it
was like a mid-porn movie and it was
like a dark apartment and I was like I
pulled it in as I cracked this ad snake
for sale and then I pulled it in the
background TV it was like porn I was
like that's the indication that she was
a person's unaware yeah and they're
trying to sell a stick with fecal matter
in the cage the upkeep was all wrong the
person's not well right what a goal that
person's apartment and be like hey here
for the steak you've never returned to
snake no now I've had I've had uh I've
had uh good luck but I know what to look
for right when they get when they got
like dirt back typos you know like yeah
if there's if there's like Capital
random capital letters and lowercase
letters
when they're trying to trade the snake
for like a game system
yeah there was recently a guy on
Craigslist trying to sell a rattlesnake
that's illegal oh
like do you need permits for these
things or no
that's way too many questions
when I get a little right under his neck
he doesn't even give a [ __ ] yeah you're
not supposed to have them and this is
crazy so I saw it on Craigslist I posted
on my Ig story I was like holy [ __ ]
someone and the rattlesnake looked
distressed it was in the S shape you
could tell the tail was rather in a
cardboard box the next day one of these
social media influences I think um what
is New York oh yeah show the rattlesnake
on the street or like on the flashlight
and the posting for that snake was in
New York and the flat iron District I
think it was the same [ __ ] snake wow
because it was a day later say either
you're the only person that put that
together I know yeah
yeah
yeah you are a pet detective no yes no
literally he is but I was I was just
because that's all bad for reptile
owners like we're joking around right
like I love these animals to these
animals it's like turn into a garden
like you know I water them right I feel
and I do care for them and I want to it
provided enrichment and I want to
educate people I want people to you know
know that that medicine creatures you
know which is what's happening today
wear your snake on the subway I see that
a lot is that safe
but it's a bit of a show-off thing and
it freaks people out I don't want to
make people feel uncomfortable like sure
before we put the lights on in here
right it was like we snake people have
it bad enough they think of us as like
tattoo dudes or ponytails you know [ __ ]
like you know but they also we don't to
make things worse they're called We're
called herps because the study of
reptiles are herpetologists yeah so I'm
a herp yeah yeah this episode's gonna be
called Sal and Chris get hurt
[Laughter]
all right why is um Pluto was taking his
tongue out like yeah because he keeps
doing that and that's what's freaking me
out because
a long slow flick like that is curious
he's just picking up his surrounding
he's smelling that's all he's doing he's
actually in in a very good place right
he's not he's not trying to hide he's
not balling up he's just curious do you
know does does it know that it's you
like it feels I have a feeling that they
do I can't say I got a feeling yeah
because uh no but wait hold on don't
talk to me anymore so you know all this
stuff about things you've thoroughly
impressed me I can't believe how much
you know but you don't know you only
have a feeling that it might know you
like so that means they don't have a
compliments like oh my God I'm impressed
by your loss but yeah you have no idea
so you don't know if that snake
recognizes you every time you get it yes
because when I uh when I hold him they
they're always super calm they smell
unbelievable
what you smell like I would say this
particular snake absolutely some
mistakes I think you just don't know
racing but I have my dad smells like Old
Spice and Newport cigarettes
every time you if you let it loose in
the CVS
you know what I stopped on my game it's
American Spirit thank you very much oh
wow look at that oh your lungs thank you
next to this call for two years now okay
dude it would be so confused in the
Bronx so I think everyone was his father
is where he gets his snakes from Mostly
the Bronx the Bronx is the for New York
City the Bronx is one of the top places
to get snakes right we I at least it's a
mix it just so happens that these two
snakes that just actually oh Pluto's
from Queens a virus from the Bronx and
uh the next one was uh online no why
didn't you wash your hands in between
each one because they can't smell snake
on you well it's just for sanitary
reasons it could happen to get into
clean your hands Chris okay
I'm sure these snakes have to breathe in
secondhand smoke hours a day
have you sanitized your hand since you
sneeze all those times which sounds it's
right in front of you have you done it
yet
[Music]
don't be a flake don't run away from
your feelings babe don't feel Don't Be
Afraid don't be ashamed don't hesitate
to say hey babe hey babe hey babe
[Music]